[Aplausos]
emprender es una de las actividades más
creativas y desafiantes que una persona
puede llegar a tener pero para que un
emprendimiento tenga relevancia e
importancia tiene que incluir tres
ingredientes muy especiales la
innovación la disrupción y el impacto
cuando hablamos de emprendimientos
hablamos de la creación de startups
hablamos del levantamiento de millones
de dólares para poder financiarlos la
transformación de innovadoras ideas de
productos a servicios y que sean reales
la creación de modelos de negocios
sustentables y vender estas empresas por
millones de dólares porque el mejor
indicador de un emprendimiento ha sido
exitoso y si se puede vender ya qué
precio y no es solamente un tema del
emprendedor de que el emprendedor se
lleve dinero es un tema que va más allá
los países también ganan del
emprendimiento
la auditora internacional pida belushi
hizo un estudio y analizó que en israel
en el año 2017
el país tuvo ingresos por
emprendimientos por más de 20 mil
millones de dólares
solo por la venta de empresas y salida
de empresas o de emprendimientos a las
bolsas en ecuador en el año 2017 ls rey
recaudo
un poquito más de 13.000 millones de
dólares es decir en israel recuperaron o
levantaron o el país recibió más o casi
el doble de lo que se recolectó en
ecuador en impuestos es decir un país
podría vivir
del emprendimiento cuando hablamos de
emprendimientos hablamos nos recordamos
del silicon valley nos recordamos de
europa
pensamos en israel las llamadas starter
nation américa latina todavía no es un
ambiente amigable para el emprendimiento
salvo ciertas excepciones como brasil
argentina o méxico colombia chile que
han hecho realmente esfuerzos y los
gobiernos han invertido en tener
entornos correctos sin embargo en
américa latina ya hay un movimiento
pujante hacia el avance en el tema de
emprendimientos y startups
si bien en ecuador vivimos problemas
gravísimos en el tema o todos los que
somos emprendedores
sin incentivos hacia el emprendimiento
sin ecosistemas o no sin ecosistemas con
pocos muy buenos pocos
ecosistemas de incubación y de startups
sin apoyo pero sin apoyo completo en
temas de inversiones o fondos de
inversión de riesgo generados por los
gobiernos muy pocos privados pero sin
embargo con esta situación en ecuador
como el resto de países de américa
latina si podemos hacer emprendimiento
disruptivo
para poder tener éxitos en el mundo el
emprendimiento hay que pasar por
fracasos no existe el emprendedor que ha
tratado o que ha llegado a tener un
éxito sin tener 5.000 caídas en el
camino a eso lo llamamos tenacidad esta
tarde quiero compartir con ustedes
parte de la experiencia que he tenido en
mis últimos 60 años y durante los
últimos 20 años como emprendedor de
alguna manera comencé a emprender cuando
no existía la palabra emprendimiento
cree un startup cuando no existía la
palabra start o levante capital cuando
no existían los fondos de capital de
riesgo como existen el día de hoy e hice
un exit exit es vender una empresa
cuando realmente el término éxito
tampoco existía creo que sigo haciendo
algunas cosas que no hay todavía
terminología para lo que estoy haciendo
en algún momento creo que la definirán
si bien nací en argentina a los 16 años
emigré a israel otro país donde me
eduqué y se crearon o se generaron las
bases de mi capacidades de
emprendimiento de emprendedor luego de
terminar mis estudios secundarios
especializados en temas de aeronáutica
ingresé al servicio militar
hice tres años de servicio militar pero
agregue dos años adicionales es
indudable que el servicio militar en
israel es uno de los ingredientes que
influyen en las personas en ese país
para poder ser emprendedores pero una de
las aptitudes que se aprende o que se
adquiere en israel haciendo el servicio
militar se refleja en una palabra que se
llama hood
justo justa quiere decir
tomen atención descaro audacia
cuestionamiento nervios de acero
imprudencia agallas atrevimiento osadía
frescura tenacidad y todo eso en una
sola palabra
aunque en muchos países podría resultar
realmente una falta de respeto tener
juntos para en israel es una actualidad
indispensable
como lo nombran dan senos en su best
seller
startup nation
la justa es la forma en que los alumnos
se dirigen a sus profesores los
empleados desafían a sus jefes y los
sargentos gestionan a sus generales
en el año 2009 87
hace 30 años llegue el ecuador como
asesor para la fuerza aérea ecuatoriana
enviado por las industrias
aeroespaciales de israel luego de nueve
años de hacer interesantísimos proyectos
y con el nacimiento de mi querido hijo
pasé un proceso de evolución y de
transformación personal muy grande y
decidí dejar para toda mi vida la
ocupación o mi ocupación con el tema
militar y me decidí a ser emprendedor
focalizado en resolver problemas que
tenían que ver con la movilidad con la
industria vehicular con el tema de las
flotas vehiculares empecé a generar mis
primeros proyectos mis primeros ocho
años fueron realmente una dura prueba de
que no es suficiente tener ganas para
emprender y no es suficiente invertir lo
que uno tiene y lo que no tiene
realmente esa época la podría recordar o
lo podría comparar como una pelea de
boxeo a 12 rounds
sin saber boxear y cada vez que me
tiraban al piso me levantaba con una
sonrisa en la cabeza en la cara pero con
golpes muy fuertes cada vez más golpeado
aprendiendo importantes lecciones
momentos en los cuales los sueños y la
tenacidad eran más importantes que el
dolor de aquellos rounds y golpes que
uno recibía
pero después de todo eso llegan las
lecciones y acaban algunas de ellas y
éstas van dirigidas hacia los
emprendedores del día de hoy y aquellos
que quieren ser emprendedores
primero primera regla
hay que aprender a soñar despiertos y
estoy hablando no de soñar mientras que
dormimos estoy hablando de soñar
despiertos desgraciadamente hay mucha
gente que no sueña suficiente
hay que soñar hay que soñar con los pies
en la tierra pero un emprendimiento
cuando uno no sueña no funciona cuando
uno sueña suficiente el empresa el
emprendimiento pasa a ser
suficientemente bueno cuando uno no
sueña suficiente el emprendimiento no
funciona
regla o lección número 2 el problema es
más importante que la solución de la
idea desgraciadamente mucha gente cree
que tiene una idea y con esa idea puede
ser un buen emprendedor pero no es
importante pensar en la idea es
importante empezar a pensar en la
solución cuando uno piensa en la
solución llega al final de cuenta a
tener muy buenas ideas no hay que
hacerlo al revés
lección número 3 yo la llamo 80-20 80%
del tiempo hay que dedicarse a pensar a
generar estrategias a evaluar y sólo el
20 por ciento del tiempo a ejecutar
lección número 4
otra vez números 10 10 80 y eso tiene
que ver con tres elementos que están en
la vida de la vida de todos nosotros
pero también en la vida de cada
emprendedor la suerte el talento y la
experiencia no todos tenemos suerte no
existe la persona que tiene suerte todo
el tiempo y podemos tener mala suerte
por lo tanto a la suerte le vamos a
dejar el 10% y nada más del 10%
talento que es el talento el talento es
la capacidad académica que tenemos lo
que aprendimos lo que sabemos por la
experiencia que adquirimos al talento no
le podemos dejar más del 10 por ciento
también por qué razón porque no sabemos
todo yo no sé todo y creo que ninguno de
ustedes tiene la capacidad de manejar un
emprendimiento conociendo todo
a la estrategia hay que darle el 80 por
ciento por qué razón porque con la
estrategia o con una buena estrategia
compensamos la falta de suerte y
compensamos la falta de talento en mi
caso yo compense mi falta de talento y
una de las cosas que hice es rodear me
no al principio después de ocho años de
haber recibido duros golpes de rodearme
de gente valiosa que me ha ayudado a
compensar mis faltas de capacidades
intelectuales de experiencia
y uno de ellos una de esas una de esas
personas que lograron compensar esa
falta de talento es uno de mis socios
llama beni saad a uno de los excelentes
o más grandes desarrolladores de
software en temas de
sistemas geográficos y él ya me viene
acompañando ya varios años pero así como
él hay otras personas
un financiero que realmente compensa mis
faltas de capacidades financieras llama
juan ugalde y otras 120 personas que
trabajan conmigo el día de hoy son el
talento que yo necesito para que mis
emprendimientos tengan éxito
lección número 5 defiende nuestros
objetivos
y no permitir que nuestros resultados se
conviertan en objetivos ya que me
refiero
normalmente pintamos un blanco
y luego tiramos la flecha
y la flecha tiene que quedar en el
centro y si no en el centro no pasa nada
pero primero pintamos el blanco qué
quiere decir definimos objetivos y luego
los cumplimos hay mucha gente que comete
un gravísimo error primero tira la
flecha y una vez que tiró la flecha
acomoda resultados y pinta el blanco
esto parece lo mismo no son son iguales
la persona que pasa después de haber
tirado las flechas piensa que esto es lo
mismo no señores eso no es lo mismo uno
está bien hecho y el otro es un error
garrafal
yo podría decir que el 80% de los
emprendedores cometen ese error y hay
que tener muchísimo cuidado
de todas maneras cada dificultad en
emprendimiento permite que se abran
nuevas oportunidades y esta es la
esencia de nosotros los emprendedores en
ecuador'
realmente tenemos muchas dificultades y
no solamente en el ecuador hay muchos
países latinoamericanos y quizás en
otras partes del mundo que sufren de lo
que sufrimos nosotros no todos son
países desarrollados pero realmente la
idea es tratar de buscar dentro de esas
problemáticas lo que nosotros podemos
rescatar y hacer de esos grandes valores
yo encontré uno de ellos que es el
ecuador tiene un mercado espectacular es
un mercado pequeño pero con gente
increíble en donde uno puede probar
muchas cosas y generar un laboratorio
para validar que los proyectos que uno
tiene son los proyectos correctos y que
funcionan correctamente y validamos los
modelos de negocios y validamos la
monetización de estos proyectos
realmente
es una gran oportunidad tener en un país
como el ecuador la posibilidad de
verificar y validar que los proyectos
pueden llegar a funcionar
y esta metodología la vengo
implementando hace muchísimos años con
un éxito increíble acá en el ecuador
generando proyectos de disrupción total
de los cuales le voy a contar sólo dos
de ellos
en el año 96 general motors en eeuu
generó un producto un servicio que
permitía poner ponían en dentro de los
autos un servicio de asistencia que la
persona que estaba en el auto podría
comunicarse con un centro de atención y
le daban atención en la ruta le daban
asistencia el servicio mecánico le daban
también navegación
trataron de incluirlo de implementarlo
en américa latina y no les fue tan bien
como pensaban en un inicio
al ver ese problema
y con un poco de spa se acuerdan todas
esas palabras entre ellas estaba la
osadía la tenacidad
de alguna manera me metí a la oficina
del presidente dejen a los muertos en
ecuador con el fin de explicarle de que
ecuador era el mejor laboratorio de
américa latina para tratar de probar que
ese proyecto podría funcionar y luego
expandirlo al resto del continente bueno
me llevo un año no solamente a mí sino a
mí ya mi equipo mis colabora de los de
mis socios negociar con llegaron motors
de que unos ilustres desconocidos en
ecuador van a implementar un proyecto
que sólo en eeuu se pudo hacer
este proyecto se llama chevystar lo
firmamos lo implementamos lo probamos en
ecuador lo generamos acá y luego lo
expandimos a colombia de venezuela
cuando venezuela todavía era una
potencia en el mundo automotriz
luego de 34 años no luego de 5 años la
empresa esa empresa que empezó un
ecuador que en ecuador sólo validó sus
modelos
la expandimos
colombia de venezuela y llegó a un valor
de 80 millones de dólares eso esa
compañía la vendimos y después los que
compraron la compañía siguieron
expandiendo la argentina brasil y méxico
un éxito total pero nació en ecuador
segundo caso
en el año 2010
viaje a san jose california a exponer
una plataforma tecnológica que habíamos
desarrollado con mi socio sacan ecuador
en la convención en esa exposición de
plataformas tecnológicas pusimos la
nuestra al lado mío puso un stand una
persona que justamente le d'israel
tratando de exponer su desconocido
proyecto que había nacido en israel este
proyecto es mamá weiss durante una
semana nadie habló con nosotros nadie me
preguntó sobre en plataforma a él nadie
le preguntó sobre ways y tuvimos una
semana para conversar durante esta
semana yo le expliqué lo que era ecuador
la capacidad que teníamos acá de validar
y probar proyectos y hacer una
incubadora para sacarlo al resto del
mundo así lo hicimos firmamos el
contrato no fue un contrato lo firmamos
una servilleta y nos dio el manejo desde
río el río yo lo llamo el río grande
méxico hasta ushuaia en argentina en un
año
perdón en dos años llegamos a levantar
13 millones de usuarios en américa
latina y la compañía posteriormente se
vendió google en 1100 millones de
dólares
weiss no nació en un ecuador nació en
israel sus fundadores
tuvieron israel
pero realmente ecuador fue el lugar que
le permitió y le consolidó su salida al
exterior
así es como todas estas pruebas y
validaciones nos han permitido
demostrarnos que en ecuador con un
ambiente no muy amigable nos permite
realmente ser disruptivos a nivel
mundial
al final de cuenta desde ecuador con
cuatro emprendimientos simultáneos un
startup en israel y uno en camino
impactando en más de siete países
habiendo levantado más de 30 millones de
dólares para mis emprendimientos siendo
desde hace un año miembro de la red de
emprendimiento más grande del mundo
llamen day board a mis 60 años no dejo
de sentirme joven emprender es una forma
de vida emprender es unasur no es un
asunto de dinero no es un tema de ganar
dinero se trata de hacer la diferencia
se trata de hacer de éste un mundo mejor
gracias
[Aplausos]